we are set up for addiction it's just
like language and cognition and all of
these other things we are the animal
which a dick other animals don't a dick
an addiction is a way of relating to the
world we don't not only a dick to drugs
we addicted to each other to chunks of
territory to behavior patterns exactly
is attachment we attach to everything I
and it's very real it's physiological I
remember years and years ago a woman
left me for a homunculus and I was
appalled and it became it became I mean
I was like vomiting every four hours
could not sleep would burst into tears
and inappropriate situations of which
there were many in my life and it was
heroin withdrawal cannot be worse than
that I mean are you kidding vomiting
every four hours and and then one night
in the middle of the night I was just
frantic because I felt like I when I was
awake I felt like I wanted to be asleep
when I was when I should have been
sleeping I couldn't sleep and I was just
dragging myself to classes I felt you
know this is crazy I should turn myself
in but they don't have crisis centers
for broken hearts what are you going to
do so so then in the middle of one of
these bouts I I went to the medicine
cabinet and this woman who had left me
had left all these these pills there and
I sorted through all these pills and
came upon a small bottle of
tranquilizers
a very mount mild tranquilizers like
valium or something well I had never
taken a valium so I said I'll take half
and I took it and the next morning or a
few hours later I went out to breakfast
and somebody came up and sat at my table
and said well how are you coping since
Hermione left you I said whoo you know
it's just jerkin and it really gave me a
respect for tranquilizing them and I was
appalled I was appalled that something
so real to me so so much me half the tab
I didn't care you know let him go and
then I realized all the people around me
this is how they deal with emotional
crisis nobody wants to feel anything
I mean the firt at the moment that an
unpleasant emotion rears its head people
go take valium or something else and cut
themselves off from feeling we addicted
to people that's the point of that story
and when they leave us suddenly it's
just like having your heroin taken away
and you become a mad thing for months
years sometimes I mean I still vibrate
from this event and it was 15 years ago
we addicted to territory this is war our
turf our land now this arises again a
consequence of Agriculture before
agriculture
nobody had land it land was something
you walked around on as you migrated
behind your herds
once it was cognized as an object and
fixed upon they were ready to knock the
other guy's brains out for setting foot
on your territory we all do this I mean
we are addicted to caffeine outrageous
caffeine addiction money sugar prey
television now this is the favorite one
to talk about because television is a
forerunner of very insidious drugs to
come it's just the crudest and the first
but imagine if after World War two a
drug had been introduced into this
country of right-thinking hard-working
decent Christian people such that 20
years after its induction the average
American citizen would be spending six
and a half hours per day involved in
this drug that's the figure for
television consumption in this country
the average American watches six and a
half hours a day of TV it is an
electronic drug it is an obsessive
behavior pattern an unconscious behavior
pattern and a physically destructive
behavior pattern I'm going to be done
more for the rebirth of hemorrhoids
specialist than any other single force
in our society so but people say well
that's not a drug that's entertainment
six and a half hours a day of
entertainment you know before electronic
media a person could regard themselves
as a great patron of let's say the
musical community and maybe they would
hear 12 live musical performances a year
when they would go to a theater I mean
Pete how many how many people in baito
how many experts on Beethoven in his
generation or the generation following
heard let's say the ninth symphony more
than several times in their intellectual
life because you know you have to get a
lot of people together and cooperating
to perform the ninth symphony we to us
the ninth symphony is an object listen
to it listen again listen again we are
able to turn experience we are able to
objectify experience and then addicted
to it well is this
add how can it be bad if it is so
written into us I don't think it is bad
I think what we have to do is choose our
addictions choose our behavior patterns
on the one can choose to be addicted to
punctuality if I'm accused of this other
people are addicted to always being late
one can be addicted to you know
meaningless sexual encounters you mean
because of the physiological level well
I think that's been much overplayed I
think I mean should we not fall in love
because we pheromonal II lock together
with this person and become a single
unified set of drives and goals the
physiological aspects of addiction have
been I think very strongly overdrawn I I
smoke cannabis every day at most
opportunities and have for years and
years I mean since I was 18 years old
every once in a while I stopped just to
see what that's like it's trivial it's
utterly easy all that happens is a shift
in behavior patterns I read more that's
what happens when I stop smoking
cannabis and yet I'm supposed to be
breaking out into cold sweats wandering
aimlessly through the streets of the
city staring up at lighted windows yeah
right so I think we give each other too
much permission to be weak in this area
what is never talked about in talk about
addiction is self-restraint I mean for
heaven's sake you know just take hold of
yourself a people ya responsibility
and if you tell people addiction is a
disease addiction is it's because you're
black it's because you're poor it's
because you're this is because you're
that you have just given them a whole
bunch of reasons not to take
responsibility for their own situation
and what is needed in these addictive
situations I think is the shock of
recognition
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]